video games like Killzone can be
expensive but thankfully we have a
certain individual here in gamespot com
who knows all about getting sweet deals
on cheaper video games you may know him
as Maxwell Maxwell McGee we know miss
Maxwell MacFarlane's Maxwell bargains
your guide to finding the hottest status
games in apparently i'm making a rain
sweet deal I had no idea that's what the
background was gonna wear this way they
came up with mega thought one it's
Madeline it used to be just like giant
like nametags a sale written across
stuff did you print your own currency is
max coin you guys want to get in early I
imagine it's gonna go like this very
quickly oh my goodness but enough about
Max coin we'll get back to that later
let's jump to this week's hottest deals
so first up on the docket is tomb raider
knows is the reboot that came out last
year and it is now free on playstation
plus if you folks out there do not have
playstation plus what is wrong with you
it is such a good deal this isn't the
definitive edition you don't get all the
fancy face work but enough about that
next up is dead nation apocalypse
edition which is also free through
PlayStation Plus for PlayStation 4 now
since it's the apocalypse addition it
also comes with the road to devastation
DLC pack and you can play for actively
with your buddies and shoot people with
flamethrowers so it's totally off that's
really good next up I am third on the
docket is dead space 2 which if you
don't have playstation plus don't worry
about it cuz it's available on steam for
679 this week only now you folks out
there gonna remember a dead space 2 came
out back in the time when dead space
games were all about being fun survival
horror games and not buddy-buddy co-op
shooter games definitely recommend that
one got on the deals docket this week
folks like bargains act thank you very
much packs all right I have loose a lot
either it's pretty great
every week oh man